what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so it is 12:30 in the morning right
now and I have recorded something like
seven or eight audio files I am
exhausted it's been all day today doing
nothing but reading comics and man I
need to get some rest
but pax West is coming up this weekend
so I gotta prep ahead of time so we are
finally jumping into blackest night and
it is about time I told you guys the
lead-up to blackest night is huge its
massive in scope I mean it's just it's
it's absolutely mind-boggling because
everything we've covered it really with
the beginning of Green Lantern's secret
origin all the way up to this point has
all led to blackest night so it's
actually really really exciting but one
thing I want you guys to keep in mind is
that this comes as part of the aftermath
of the death of Batman now the way this
all plays out and really the the nature
of blackest night is to kind of hit home
at the idea of character resurrections
those of you guys who are new to comic
books the character resurrections were
never really a thing until the death of
Superman and the reason why was because
for the most part when a character was
killed off they usually just stayed dead
there was really no sense I'm bringing
them back and it was really important
for writers to follow that trend because
whenever they wrote stories were
character die there was a finality to it
it was the idea that woola's characters
dead now and they're never gonna come
back
the death of Superman and then the
return of Superman
basically cheapened it he created the
standard were it essentially said so
long as there's some kind of caveat
whether it's time-travel whether it's
going into no healing healing matrix
whatever it is as long as a writer
creates some sort of caveat any
character can come back so Colossus for
example sacrificed his life in order to
cure the legacy virus this virus that
was just sweeping through the entirety
of the mutant and even human community
like a plague and then following that he
was basically resurrected you know by by
Joss Whedon so this whole idea that the
characters don't really state anymore
all really has its roots in the death of
Superman with Batman he essentially died
during Final Crisis now of course we'll
talk a little bit more about this as we
go through this video but the idea here
is that we initially pick up with the
scarred Guardian now we don't really
know who the scar guardian is we just
know that it's this Guardian whose face
is scarred now the reason for this is
because this is one of the guardians
that faced off against the anti
during the events of Sinestro Corps war
I'll keep in mind the anti-monitor
basically channels antimatter energy
whereas everything in the main DC
Universe is positive energy in this
story it's just the idea that if
positive matter is touched by antimatter
it'll begin to erode and so that's why
the Guardians face is so scarred and so
screwed up is because it was basically
touched by the anti-monitor which began
to erode its face away now the response
to this was that as this Guardian was
essentially on the brink of death it was
suddenly met by the entity necrons one
of the many entities that exist as part
of the emotional spectrum keep in mind
within the DC universe you have the
emotional spectrum and the emotional
spectrum is just a reflection of
sentient life and so as long as there
are beings out there alien human
otherwise who feel anger who feel love
who feel compassion whatever the case
may be that part of the emotional
spectrum will exist because of the fact
that it's fed by those very emotions
likewise because there are beings that
exist a time will come when they die and
so the Black Lantern Corps represents
the concept of death the idea is that
while this Guardian was basically
experiencing what amounted to near-death
experience so to speak it was met with
nekron because each of these different
parts of the emotional spectrum
basically has a kind of entity that
represents it which is to say all the
emotion in the universe you know all the
fear for example in the universe
coalesce into a being that embodies all
the fear that exists in the universe of
course that being coming in the form of
parallax these are how all these
different things work in the case of the
black Lantern's the concept of death
coalesce into a being called necron
meaning that necron seems to be
basically undefeatable so long as
there's life in existence necron will
never die just because of the fact that
you know necron represents the concept
of something dying again it gets really
kind of crazy and really sort of
mind-boggling when we get to these
levels of thinking but the cool thing is
about this is about as complicated as it
gets so the funny thing about this is
that this guardian basically gives us
this sort of rundown of the really the
history of the universe when it comes to
these various lanterns as well as you
know the Manhunters that exist so in
order to follow this trend is pretty
self-explanatory but in order to follow
this trend what we know is that in the
beginning there was just the creation of
the universe
however the universe came into existence
following this there was the very first
race in existence called the mountains
and the mountains had basically evolved
an
to the point where they basically him to
realize that emotion was the source of
all problems in the universe a person is
struggling financially they get angry
and in their anger they get envious in
their envy they take what somebody else
has this is basically the the root of
all evil emotion itself that's how they
guardians of the universe viewed it and
so the Malthusians began the process of
basically casting off emotion now DC
rebirth comes back and ties into a lot
of that stuff with volthoom
providing a lot of information we didn't
have before and we'll cover all that
once we get around to like wrath of the
first Lantern and different things like
that but the long and short of it for
this video right now is that the
Malthusians had basically cast out
emotion and then began the process of
creating this sort of universal police
force which came in the form of these
Android Manhunters now the problem with
this is that these Android Manhunters
were eventually went awry now this all
ties into the end to something called
crona's gauntlet which is to say a very
primitive version of the Green Lantern
race basically and what we know is that
Crona was one of the Malthusians one of
the guardians of the universe who wanted
to see the beginning of all things and
so the result was that when he did this
he effectively created all evil he
basically came you know more less went
back in time and created the
anti-monitor leading to the collapse of
the multiverse and all that kind of
crazy stuff but the idea here is that
with Crona being a bad guy Crona
actually messed with the programming of
the of the Manhunters which in turn sent
them on this murderous crusade that's
where the red lanterns come from and all
those things but in response to the
Manhunters going awry becoming evil the
guardians of the universe came to the
realization that if sentient beings are
what basically power the emotional
spectrum then the best way to tap into
the emotional spectrum is to use
sentient beings but in order to do that
they can't just give them all kinds of
crazy power there have to be these sort
of standards these checks and balances
that ensure that if a person is given a
ring that allows them to channel
directly into the emotion of willpower
that they won't use it for evil deeds
now of course we know that
Sinestro ended up doing that but the
idea was that the guardians of the
universe created the Green Lantern rings
and then had them go out and seek people
who were deemed to be worthy hosts thus
was born the Green Lantern Corps the
issue with this is that along the way
the Green Lantern's had basically
encountered Atrocitus the first of the
red lanterns and Atrocitus by you know
looking into the future by casting
differ
prophecies had basically learned of
something called the prophecy of
blackest night this idea that all these
Lantern cores would rise all these
Lantern cores would go to war some
unknown dark force would come into
existence and then basically wipe out
all emotion in the universe and then
wipe everything out and all life would
basically cease to exist because of the
fact that this basically created a
scenario where the guardians of the
universe had to face the idea that their
lives their existence were not under
their control they in turn chose to
ignore it now we're a couple of the
guardians ganthet and sayd where they
were basically banished from the
guardians of the universe for refusing
to ignore the prophecy of blackest night
one of them the scarred guardian
actually began the process of ensuring
the blackest night came into existence
and so that's where a lot of this stuff
ends up happening it's basically
gathering all these different things
together these different resources
pushing the Guardians operating behind
the scenes moving them in the direction
of ensuring that this War of the Lantern
Corps is this war of light begins to
take place and so what our story does is
it actually transitions over to a guy
named William hand now this is one of
the reasons why it is that I said that
with the whole Jeff John's run on Green
Lantern that he would just kind of
introduce a character and this character
would pop up in a little bit of a story
over here and then they'd never be seen
or heard from again for like a year and
a half this is one of those instances
William hand was a guy who popped up in
the secret origin of Hal Jordan and all
we knew about him at the time was that
he was just obsessed with the concept of
death now the idea was that with the
secret origin of Hal Jordan designed to
go back and reach how Hal Jordan the
Green Lantern's origin story from the
time he first appeared in DC Comics all
the way up to the modern day we ended up
finding out that William hand was there
when Hal Jordan first became the Green
Lantern he's simply been operating
behind the scenes the entire time the
question became what is this harbinger
of the Black Lantern Corps what was he
doing during this time and that's why
this is so cool this tale of the Black
Lantern because it's basically the life
and times of the first Black Lantern the
person who had basically uh sure in this
Corps that would try to eliminate all
things in existence now what we know
about William Han is again referencing
this to me a little bit of history with
his character he was obsessed with death
what this tells us is how obsessed with
death he was there wasn't like one day
he just said you know what I think death
is cool it's
it was a gradual thing it was him
dealing with his family who were
essentially morticians or at least his
father who was a mortician watching the
things that he did and becoming enamored
by the idea of death in the same way
that people will fire up a video game
and say this is the greatest video game
I've ever played and I'm gonna play it
all the time because it's the absolute
best William hand loved death the exact
same way he was enamored by it he
studied it he always wanted to be
surrounded by it he was uncomfortable
with living normal human beings instead
he was more comfortable when he was
surrounded by the dead the result of
this is that back when Atrocitus you
know the the harbinger of the Red
Lantern Corps first popped up on earth
again Atrocitus had looked to the future
and seen that a guy named William hand
was going to bring about this blackest
night this war of light and so the
result is that Atrocitus sought to
eliminate William hand this led to the
intervention of both Sinestro and Hal
Jordan the newest introduction to the
Green Lantern Corps working together and
then taking Atrocitus out following this
William Han just remained behind the
scenes for the most part the weapon of
Atrocitus this you know device it was
able to channel Greenland Green Lantern
energy was essentially left behind and
in using this what ended up happening is
William Han just sort of became this guy
that was going to the process of trying
to implement death everywhere he went he
simply just obsessed with a concept of
killing things now of course this leads
to him donning his costume basically
becoming black hand this is of course
references all the way back to the old
school Green Lantern stories where black
hand was very much a minor villain of
Hal Jordan this expands on that and it
basically says this is the road that
William hand took that led him to
basically be coming to the harbinger of
the Black Lantern Corps now the other
half of this is that because William
hand was operating behind the scenes the
entire time that Hal Jordan was the
Green Lantern he was privy to all these
different changes so when Jon Stewart
first popped up as the second Green
Lantern on earth followed by Guy Gardner
followed by Kyle Rayner the events of
Emerald Twilight when he basically began
to channel all this fear became a host
for the living embodiment of fear in the
form of parallax wiped out all the Green
Lantern's these are all the things that
William hand was seeing he was watching
them happen the idea here was that he
had seen more and more superheroes die
more and more often the issue at this is
that each time for the most part they
kept coming back
so characters like digger Harkness Ted
Kord Maxwell Lord Himself who was killed
by Wonder Woman in response for shooting
Ted Kord had all these different things
that existed out there the death of John
Jones Aquaman or at least the perceived
death of Aquaman you know all these
different things have gone into the idea
that as far as William hand is concerned
what is dead should stay dead in his
mind death is really a living entity
people who die should not be allowed to
return and in his mind was Superman
having quote-unquote died only to
basically be healed with Hal Jordan
quote-unquote dying only to come back
after being taken by the specter with
Kilowog with Bart Allen with Barry Allen
dying and then coming back to life
during final crisis again these are all
the ideas that William Hann believes
that death has been cheated and so
because of this and his goal is to
basically find a way to begin the
process of giving death the people it
rightfully deserves this coincides with
his desire to just inflict as much death
as he possibly can to kill anything he
can where he can't and some of the first
victims are basically his family he goes
through and begins killing each member
of his family ultimately turning this
device on himself now the reason why
this matters is because when this
happens it's basically him fully handing
himself over to necron the entity of
death and that's really the way it works
with these different Lantern cores right
I mean you know for example if we take
the Red Lanterns it was really Atrocitus
just experiencing absolute rage over the
fact that his family had been
obliterated by the Manhunters the result
was that as he began to channel this
rage as he looked into the future and
saw he was going to be the harbinger of
the Red Lantern Corps He fulfilled that
prophecy by creating the Red Lantern
Corps by forcing the creation of a Red
Lantern power battery and then a Red
Lantern central power battery it was
just working through the emotion of rage
every single core always has that one
person that creates it and that person
goes through all these different steps
and all these different processes this
journey of sorts that ultimately leads
to the formation of that Court with
William hand it's a little bit different
it's not like the scar guardian shows up
basically spews this Black Lantern ring
out which in turn attaches itself to
William hand and
as you are going to be my harbinger for
the Black Lantern Corps it's not like
this scarred Guardian started spitting
out all these Black Lantern rings and
they all just started going around
because then the question is who would
they go to this is basically the core of
death and so the only thing that really
can be done here is for William Han to
begin the process of resurrecting the
dead and that's why this is so cool is
because at this point we switch over to
the perspective of the death of Batman
through the eyes of Barry Allen the
flash and Hal Jordan himself now this is
told from a variety of different ways
but when it came to the death of Batman
it's really more of a misnomer Batman
being hit by the Omega beams of Darkseid
during Final Crisis was basically this
idea that they the DC could essentially
remove Batman from the landscape for a
time and then tell a story of his
eventual return what ended up happening
is Batman was just time displaced that's
all it was he was thrown back to the
very early days of humanity and that was
really it now of course this was DC's
attempt to basically set the stage to go
back and retell this grandiose story for
the origin of Batman in the end it
didn't matter because they rebooted like
two years later but the whole idea here
is that from the perspective of Hal
Jordan and Barry Allen they don't know
that Batman's all the way back at the
early days of humanity as far as they're
aware Batman is dead now the other half
of this is that how Jordan begins
talking about the idea of how people
respond to those individuals who have
been killed keep in mind when Barry
Allen died he died as a hero he died
basically saving the multiverse you know
and so there were all these different
responses to his death all these
different ideas that people were coming
back people were saying oh man we have
to celebrate the life and times of Barry
Allen for Hal Jordan it wasn't that way
I mean we talked about this a little bit
ago how Jordan's life has been mired in
just controversy and struggle and strife
but as parallax he didn't die a hero
nobody looked at Hal Jordan said oh man
that's so sad this once-great Green
Lantern had a fall from grace but we
should remember him the way he used to
be not at all people looked at him and
said he's a bad guy he is a villain he
died a coward's death he went out like a
madman and that is the legacy that's
been haunting Hal Jordan ever since
remember with the whole run of Geoff
Johns Green Lantern when he originally
started killing all those original Green
Lantern's of course we ended up finding
out that some survived the
lanterns as they're referred to but the
idea is they look at him and say you
betrayed us you tried to kill us Batman
himself you know despite the fact that
Batman in Hal Jordan were extremely
close friends when Hal Jordan became a
villain and sort of calling himself
parallax he betrayed the trust of Batman
and that was a trust that was broken
that took time to reform and so again
this is the whole you know legacy that
he's dealing with this is the aftermath
of the events that he's coping with at
the same time Batman was only one of the
more recent deaths in Caly books William
hands goal is to essentially begin
resurrecting all these guys make them
his Lantern court in an effort to start
killing off all these different beings
that exists all throughout the universe
itself so again this leads into a
massive calamity which ultimately goes
into brightest day and it goes until you
know the whole like white lanterns and
all kinds of cool stuff and this is when
we start getting into the cool stories
this is when we start running into like
the main superheroes getting Lantern
rings and different things like that the
white lantern Justice League is when we
get into all this all this crazy cool
stuff but with that being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explained and make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob port if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]